Hilary Clinton was on last night's
Grammys was on last night's Grammys yeah
Hillary lost to Bruno Mars despite
beating him by three million votes why
dies for Hillary right that's the key
[Applause]
yesterday after the Grammys jay-z got
into a Twitter feud with President Trump
hmm jay-z and president Trump in a
Twitter feud yeah it turns out the most
powerful man in the world doesn't like
President Trump
[Applause]
I'm working on yeah
I need more I need to grow this longer
in front in a new interview President
Trump revealed that he tweets in bed
yeah
when asked if this manasa fist were true
Melania said how the hell would I know
where are you going I'll be back I
picked her and every scene just sneaking
away big news in baseball after numerous
complaints from Native Americans the
Cleveland Indians decided they're going
to get rid of their mascot chief wahoo
in 2019 yeah yeah the Indians said we
realize our mascots really offensive and
racially insensitive so we're gonna wait
a year and then get rid of it weird
story in Florida a seven-year-old boy
was arrested for punching his teacher
seven-year-old boy yeah or as they call
that in Florida a prodigy these shows
promise on Thursday KFC announced that
Colonel Sanders will now be played by
Reba McEntire Reba McEntire people have
not been this shocked since 2007 when I
took over for the Wendy's girl remember
that that was
[Applause]
their stock went down 95%
you